On va avoir en deuxième partie de soirée, donc aujourd'hui, une séance de questions-réponses ouvertes, comme je les appelle.
Pour ceux qui n'ont jamais, peut-être certains d'entre vous n'ont jamais assisté à ce genre de temps qu'on a rarement, mais voilà, de temps en temps.
Donc, on donne la possibilité à tous ceux qui le souhaitent d'envoyer des questions.
Il n'y a pas de thème précis. Parfois, on dirige un peu plus, mais là, c'était vraiment ouvert.
Et puis, on essaye, c'est souvent moi qui fais, mais d'ailleurs, Stéphane qui est ici pourra également compléter les réponses s'il le souhaite.
On essaie de traiter un maximum de questions.
Vous verrez, comme ce soir, il y en a qui, parfois volontairement, on passe plus de temps dessus parce qu'il y a beaucoup,
enfin, c'est assez profitable pour développer plusieurs points à partir d'une seule question.
Et puis, souvent, après la réponse, il y a des questions qui viennent aussi auxquelles on prend le temps de répondre.
Donc, c'est rare qu'on puisse traiter toutes les questions qui ont été envoyées.
Donc, ne soyez pas frustrés si c'est le cas, que vous avez envoyé une question et qu'on ne la traite pas ce soir.
Généralement, je les garde de côté pour les sessions d'après.
Ou alors, s'il y a besoin d'une réponse plus rapide, je le fais directement à la personne qui le demande.
Donc, voilà.
On va commencer tout de suite par une première question.
Je vais d'abord vous lire la question.
Puis, je donnerai un petit peu de contexte par la suite.
Et puis, ne vous inquiétez pas si quand je lis la question, il y a des termes que vous ne comprenez pas tout de suite ou des notions.
Justement, ça sera éclairci un peu plus tard dans la réponse.
Il faudra juste être un petit peu patient le temps qu'on arrive sur ces termes-là.
D'accord ?
Donc, voilà.
Je vais d'abord vous citer telle qu'elle, la première question telle qu'elle a été envoyée.
J'ai été très troublé par le partage sur le groupe EBN, donc le groupe signal de notre église, le partage de notre frère Nathanael, donc moi-même, le vendredi 17 octobre.
C'était une citation que j'ai envoyée qui s'appelait « Adam versus Christ ».
Donc, d'abord, parce que l'auteur dit, dans cette citation, « Ainsi, la mort du nouvel Adam va tirer l'humanité tout entière de la prison ténébreuse où elle languissait depuis tant de siècles et l'introduire dans la liberté des enfants de Dieu ».
C'est une déclaration ouvertement universaliste.
Il n'y a que le peuple élu par Dieu en Jésus-Christ qui est tiré de sa prison ténébreuse et non pas l'humanité tout entière.
Puis, considérant l'auteur Jean-Joseph Gomme, que je ne nommerai pas monseigneur, qui est un prêtre catholique romain, partisan du courant ultramontaniste, courant qui affirme la primauté spirituelle et juridictionnelle du pape, ainsi que son infaillibilité.
Par conséquent, ma question est, quelle était la motivation derrière ce partage et surtout, est-ce que la chose a été adressée au sein du Conseil des Anciens ? »
Fin de citation. Donc voilà la question avec son préambule et puis deux questions à la fin.
Au départ, pour ne rien vous cacher, je pensais répondre. Je pense que c'est un frère, s'il a bien conjugué ses phrases, ça semble être un frère, ou une sœur, peu importe, qui a posé cette question.
Je pensais lui répondre en privé. Mais ma femme m'a rappelé que j'avais envoyé cette citation sur le groupe de l'Église, donc que tout le monde a pu la lire.
Et puis aussi que cette question a été posée dans un sens publiquement. Tous ceux qui sont allés sur l'espace de questions-réponses ont pu potentiellement la lire, en avoir connaissance.
Et donc je pense qu'à cause de ces deux raisons-là, c'est important que j'y réponde dans le cadre de ce question-réponses, surtout qu'elle concerne quelque chose que j'ai personnellement envoyé.
Donc je remercie le ou la membre, si c'est un membre d'ailleurs, peut-être que c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas encore membre de l'Église qui a envoyé cette question.
Et je tiens à dire que cette question est pertinente et qu'elle est légitime.
Et c'est pour ça que je tiens à prendre du temps ce soir pour y répondre correctement.
C'est la question, ou plutôt la réponse qui sera la plus longue ce soir.
Ceci pour ça qu'on la prend en premier.
Ce n'est pas parce que j'ai hâte de me justifier, mais c'est vraiment parce que ça va nous permettre d'aborder, de clarifier plusieurs sujets importants qui concernent notamment le langage biblique sur la portée universelle du sacrifice du Christ.
Et aussi l'usage légitime qu'on peut faire d'auteurs faillibles, justement, avec lesquels on peut avoir des désaccords qui sont parfois même nombreux et profonds.
Donc voilà, il y a deux aspects à cette question, ou plutôt au préambule des deux questions.
Il y a le contenu de la citation en elle-même, et notamment cette phrase qui pose problème sur potentiellement l'universalisme.
Et il y a l'auteur de la citation, qui est pointé du doigt aussi.
Donc je vais commencer à répondre sur la préoccupation qui concerne l'aspect, selon la personne qui a posé cette question, ouvertement universaliste de la citation.
Commençons donc par relire cette citation que j'avais envoyée sur le groupe Signal, et que tout le monde ici n'a pas forcément lue, ou que la plupart ont dû oublier aussi.
Donc voilà, je cite en entier, puis on reviendra sur les quelques phrases qui posent problème.
Pourquoi Pilate ne proposa-t-il pas de délivrer Dimas ou Gestas ?
Sans doute parce qu'il n'était pas assez odieux à la populace qu'il ne méprisait pas la guerre de grand chemin à laquelle beaucoup de gens du peuple prenaient part.
Bon ça, vous n'avez pas besoin de retenir ça, c'est ici que ça commence.
Ici, nous entrons dans la série des profonds mystères qui vont se succéder jusqu'à la mort de notre Seigneur et de ses deux compagnons.
Deux hommes sont en présence.
Le nouvel Adam, tout couvert de plaies.
Le vieil Adam, tout couvert de crimes.
Le nouvel Adam, représenté par l'homme Dieu, se laissant condamner pour sauver le vieil Adam.
Barabbas, représentant le vieil Adam, est sauvé par la condamnation du nouveau.
Comme le juste par excellence personnifie toute l'humanité régénérée, le grand scélérat personnifie l'humanité dégradée et depuis 4000 ans coupable de sédition, de meurtre et de vol.
À peine prononcée, la condamnation du juste ouvre à Barabbas les portes de sa prison.
Ainsi, la mort du nouvel Adam va tirer l'humanité tout entière de la prison ténébreuse où elle languissait depuis tant de siècles et l'introduire dans la liberté des enfants de Dieu.
Fin de citation donc de Monsieur ou Monseigneur, tel qu'est son titre officiel, Gôme, dans Biographie évangélique, tome 1, Les deux larrons.
Donc je commence, comme je disais, par répondre à la première question.
Pour le coup, voilà la première question, je ne suis pas encore sur le préambule, qui a été posée.
Ce qui m'a motivé à faire ce partage, d'accord ?
Donc, on sortait ce soir-là, c'était un vendredi, de l'étude biblique, dans laquelle notre pasteur, par la grâce de Dieu, nous avait magnifiquement exposé justement ce parallèle entre le premier Adam et Jésus-Christ, le second Adam.
Là où le premier avait dramatiquement échoué en nous entraînant, nous, toute l'humanité à sa suite, qu'il représentait, dans le péché, la mort éternelle en enfer,
et bien le second avait glorieusement réussi, délivrant la nouvelle humanité qu'il représentait de l'enfer pour l'élever à sa suite au paradis.
Et j'étais encore émerveillé par cette méditation, lorsque je suis tombé sur cette citation,
qui reprend ce parallèle entre le premier Adam et le second, dans le contexte du procès de notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Barabbas est à ce moment-là, en effet, la personnification de l'humanité qui est représentée par le premier Adam,
une humanité pécheresse, justement condamnée par Dieu pour ses fautes.
Et les Juifs manifestent la réalité de leur cœur pécheur en préférant délivrer un criminel,
si cela leur permet de tuer l'innocent fils de Dieu, le Messie promis, le second Adam.
Et ce qui m'a particulièrement touché, c'est qu'avant même la substitution pénale sur la croix,
Jésus, le juste, l'innocent, prend littéralement la place d'un pécheur, d'un coupable.
Barabbas est immédiatement délivré par la condamnation injuste de Jésus-Christ.
Avant même sa mort, nous voyons déjà l'efficacité du sacrifice substitutif du Christ.
Christ prend la place du plus grand des pécheurs.
Et donc cette citation venait compléter l'émerveillement qui était le mien à ce moment-là,
suite à cette étude biblique, et c'est ce qui m'a poussé simplement à la partager sur le groupe de l'Église.
Donc voilà pour le contexte et ce qui m'a poussé à faire ce partage.
Donc revenons maintenant à cette phrase qui a perturbé celui ou celle qui a posé la question.
Ainsi, la mort du nouvel Adam va tirer l'humanité tout entière de la prison ténébreuse où elle languissait depuis tant de siècles.
Et la personne ajoute ensuite, la personne qui a posé la question, c'est une déclaration ouvertement universaliste.
Il n'y a que le peuple élu par Dieu en Jésus-Christ qui est tiré de sa prison ténébreuse et non pas l'humanité tout entière.
Donc l'universalisme, qu'est-ce que c'est ? C'est la conviction que certains ont que tous les êtres humains seront finalement sauvés et atteindront la vie éternelle.
Indépendamment de leurs croyances, de leurs actions ou de leur repentir pendant leur vie terrestre.
Peu importe ce que les hommes font durant leur vie, à la fin, Dieu, dans une forme de grâce qui n'est pas biblique, les sauvera tous et nous serons tous au paradis.
C'est ça, l'universalisme.
Et avant de revenir plus tard sur son cas, sachez que Mgr ou M. Gaume n'était pas universaliste.
Il croyait en la portée universelle de l'offre du salut.
Le Christ est mort pour tous.
Mais il affirmait aussi la nécessité de la conversion et la réalité de la damnation éternelle en enfer pour ceux qui refusent cette grâce.
Donc sa pensée reflète simplement la doctrine catholique traditionnelle qui distingue entre la suffisance universelle de la rédemption, donc Christ est mort pour tous,
et son efficacité conditionnelle.
Seuls ceux qui croient et se repentent seront sauvés.
Donc c'est un théologien catholique synergiste qui défend donc la synergie entre la grâce divine et le libre arbitre humain,
c'est-à-dire que Dieu donne la grâce premièrement, mais que l'homme doit librement y coopérer et que le salut peut être perdu aussi, après avoir été acquis.
Donc ce n'est pas du tout ma position.
Ce n'est pas du tout la position de l'Église Bonne Nouvelle.
Mais nous pouvons malgré tout affirmer ici que cet auteur n'a pas de position de manière générale et dans ce texte non plus universaliste vis-à-vis du salut des hommes.
On ne peut pas l'accuser de ça.
On peut l'accuser d'être arménien, comme on le verra plus tard.
Arménien, pas arménien.
Il y en a qui font encore la...
On ne peut pas accuser les Arméniens d'être arménien, d'accord ?
Voilà, donc on peut lui faire ce reproche-là, mais pas d'être universaliste.
Ensuite, si l'on met de côté les convictions générales de l'auteur qu'on vient de mentionner ici, et qu'on isole cette phrase,
je peux comprendre qu'on puisse l'interpréter de cette manière.
Je peux comprendre qu'elle soit ambiguë.
Toutefois, regardez dans la même citation qu'on a lue, ce que l'auteur dit juste avant.
Comme le juste par excellence, donc Christ, personnifie toute l'humanité régénérée.
Le grand scélérat personnifie l'humanité dégradée.
Donc on voit bien ici qu'il s'agit de deux humanités, d'accord ?
L'une dégradée, personnifiée par Barabbas et représentée par le premier Adam,
et l'autre régénérée, personnifiée et représentée par le second Adam, Jésus-Christ.
Et c'est sur cette base qu'il faut lire la phrase suivante.
La mort du nouvel Adam va tirer l'humanité toute entière de la prison ténébreuse.
L'humanité régénérée.
D'accord ?
Et en réalité, c'est un langage que nous retrouvons dans la Bible.
Certains versets, si on les isole du reste de la Bible, peuvent aussi être très troublants.
Et sont utilisés, entre autres, par les Arméniens pour justifier la portée universelle de la mort du Christ.
Et le choix de l'homme comme condition de son salut.
Donc voyons maintenant quelques-uns de ces passages dont je parle.
Tout d'abord, deux versets où l'apôtre Paul établit ce parallèle entre Adam et Christ, le nouvel Adam,
entre le premier et le second.
Le premier qui a plongé toute l'humanité dans la mort,
et le second qui a offert la résurrection à toute l'humanité, selon ces versets.
1 Corinthiens 15, versets 21 à 22.
Car puisque la mort est venue par un homme,
c'est aussi par un homme qu'est venue la résurrection des morts.
En effet, comme tous meurent en Adam,
de même, tous revivront dans le Christ.
Alors, est-ce que Paul serait universaliste ?
Non, mais il affirme que si c'est en Adam que tout homme meurt,
c'est en Christ que tout homme ressuscite.
Il y a un seul représentant de l'humanité qui l'a plongé dans la mort,
et un seul représentant d'une nouvelle humanité qui l'a fait naître de nouveau.
Ces versets affirment que Jésus-Christ est le seul sauveur de l'humanité et qu'il n'en a pas d'autre.
Tous ceux qui meurent, meurent en Adam,
et tous ceux qui revivent, revivent en Christ.
Deux autres versets.
Le premier qui exprime cette réalité d'une humanité prisonnière du pouvoir des ténèbres.
C'est mentionné par l'auteur de cette citation.
Colossiens 1, 13 à 14.
« Il nous a délivré du pouvoir des ténèbres
et nous a transféré dans le royaume de son Fils bien-aimé
en qui nous avons la rédemption, la rémission des péchés. »
Ce n'est pas ici un passage problématique,
c'est juste pour montrer que c'est un langage, un vocabulaire biblique aussi.
Et le second passage, qui lui par contre pourrait aussi se lire de manière universaliste.
Hébreux 2, 14 à 15.
« Puisque donc les enfants participent au sang et à la chair,
lui aussi, Jésus-Christ, y a participé,
afin de détruire par sa mort celui qui a la puissance de la mort, c'est-à-dire le diable,
et de libérer tous ceux que la crainte de la mort retenait toute leur vie dans l'esclavage. »
Tous ceux.
Est-ce que cette dernière phrase veut dire que Jésus a effectivement libéré tous les hommes ?
Car ce sont bien tous les hommes, n'est-ce pas,
que la crainte de la mort retenait toute leur vie dans l'esclavage,
et non pas que certains hommes.
Et dans ce texte, Galate 4, versets 4 à 5.
« Mais lorsque les temps ont été accomplis,
Dieu a envoyé son fils, né d'une femme, né sous la loi,
afin qu'il racheta ceux qui étaient sous la loi,
afin que nous ressuscions l'adoption. »
Est-ce que cela veut dire que Jésus a racheté tout homme ?
Car c'est bien tout homme, n'est-ce pas, qui est sous la loi,
et qui est donc retenu en esclavage par la crainte de la mort.
Et lisons deux passages pour finir
et conclure sur le langage biblique par rapport à ce sujet.
De Corinthiens 5, 14 à 15.
« L'amour du Christ nous presse,
parce que nous estimons que si un seul est mort pour tous,
tous sont donc morts,
et qu'il est mort pour tous,
afin que ceux qui vivent ne vivent plus pour eux-mêmes,
mais pour celui qui est mort et ressuscité pour eux. »
Et 1 Jean 2, verset 2.
« Il est lui-même une victime de propitiation pour nos péchés,
non seulement pour les nôtres,
mais aussi pour ceux du monde entier. »
Donc il y a un sens où l'œuvre du Christ,
sa vie, sa mort, sa résurrection,
a une portée universelle.
Avant que Dieu le Fils ne s'incarne sur terre,
l'humanité vivait,
on pourrait dire à part Israël,
la nation d'Israël,
l'humanité vivait sous la domination du diable.
« Esclaves du péché,
et dans la crainte de la mort.
Dieu le Père envoya son Fils
pour être la lumière des nations,
selon les mots du prophète Esaïe. »
Jésus-Christ lui-même affirma
« Je suis la lumière du monde. »
Et l'apôtre Jean écrivit,
« En elle, la parole,
c'est-à-dire le Christ incarné,
était la vie.
Et la vie était la lumière des hommes. »
Donc la vie,
les enseignements,
les œuvres,
la mort,
la résurrection
et la glorification du Christ,
le Messie de Dieu,
tout cela a détruit le pouvoir du diable
qui maintenait sa domination sur l'humanité
par l'obscurité spirituelle,
le mensonge
et la mort.
Et désormais,
depuis que Christ est venu sur terre,
son évangile parcourt le monde entier
et délivre les hommes
de cette emprise satanique
par la lumière de la vérité
et par la résurrection spirituelle.
Et c'est dans ce sens
qu'il faut comprendre
la portée universelle
de l'œuvre de Christ.
C'est un changement de paradigme
pour l'humanité.
On passe d'une époque
de plusieurs millénaires
d'obscurité spirituelle.
Christ vient
et la lumière chasse ses ténèbres
et l'évangile progresse
à travers le monde.
C'est dans ce sens
que toute l'humanité
est libérée de sa prison ténébreuse.
Il ne s'agit pas ici
du salut de chaque individu
mais de l'état
de l'humanité
de manière générale.
La lumière du Christ
chasse progressivement
les ténèbres
qui maintenaient
les hommes captifs
de l'enfer.
Si Christ n'était pas venu
nous révéler
à la perfection le Père
mourir,
ressusciter,
il n'y aurait aucun espoir
pour l'humanité
qui resterait captive
de l'enfer.
Et si vous faites attention,
vous verrez que ces passages
qu'on a lus
mettent plutôt l'emphase
sur le fait que l'humanité
n'a qu'un sauveur.
Si elle fut plongée
dans le péché
et la mort par un seul homme,
Adam,
elle ne sera régénérée
et glorifiée
qu'en un seul homme,
Jésus-Christ.
Et donc,
dans ce sens,
Jésus-Christ est en effet
le représentant
de toute l'humanité
régénérée.
Et pour faire le lien
avec la fête
de la réforme demain,
voici un commentaire
de Jean Calvin
sur 1 Jean 2,
verset 2,
qu'on a lu.
Et vous verrez au passage
qu'il condamne vivement
l'universalisme
avec son vocabulaire
qui lui est propre
et qu'il approuve
une certaine compréhension
de ce texte
même si lui
en a une autre.
Et je reviendrai
sur cela juste après.
Donc voici le commentaire
qu'il fait
sur 1 Jean 2,
verset 2.
Ici,
une question peut être soulevée.
Comment les péchés
du monde entier
ont-ils été expiés ?
Je passe sous silence
les rêveries des fanatiques
qui, sous ce prétexte,
étendent le salut
à tous les réprouvés
et par conséquent
jusqu'à Satan lui-même.
Une chose si monstrueuse
ne mérite aucune réfutation.
Ceux qui veulent éviter
cette absurdité
ont dit que le Christ
a souffert suffisamment
pour le monde entier
mais efficacement
seulement pour les élus.
Cette solution
a communément prévalu
dans les écoles.
Quoi que j'admette
que cette distinction
soit vraie,
je nie toutefois
qu'elle convienne
à ce passage
car l'intention de Jean
n'était autre
que de rendre
ce bienfait commun
à toute l'Église.
Ainsi,
sous le mot
tous
ou le monde entier,
il n'inclut pas
les réprouvés
mais il désigne
ceux qui croiront
aussi bien que ceux
qui étaient alors dispersés
en divers lieux du monde.
C'est-à-dire
l'Église universelle
à travers le monde.
Car la grâce de Christ
se manifeste véritablement
comme il se doit
lorsqu'elle est déclarée
être la seule
véritable source
de salut
pour le monde.
Il appuie sur cette
unicité de Christ
comme sauveur
pour tout homme.
Donc l'avantage
de ce commentaire
c'est aussi de vous montrer
que les mots
tout homme
ou toute humanité
ou le monde entier
peuvent avoir un sens différent
en fonction de leur contexte
dans la Bible.
Beaucoup,
beaucoup,
beaucoup de débats
ont eu lieu
notamment à l'époque
de la réforme
et entre les réformateurs
sur cette distinction.
Le Christ a souffert
suffisamment
pour le monde entier
mais efficacement
seulement
pour les élus.
Cela veut dire
que le Christ
est si parfait
qu'une seule goutte
de son sang
pourrait sauver
toute l'humanité.
Si cela était
la volonté de Dieu.
Mais son sang
ne sauve que ceux
que Dieu a choisi
d'attirer à lui
par son Esprit Saint
et à qui il accorde
le don de la foi.
De 1618 à 1619
des théologiens réformés
de toute l'Europe
se sont réunis
à Dortrèche
aux Pays-Bas
pour répondre
aux affirmations
de Jacobus Arminius
qui était lui-même
un pasteur réformé
un professeur de théologie
à l'université de Lede.
Et c'est d'après son nom
que l'on qualifia
par la suite
ceux qui croient
à une forme de libre arbitre,
à une rédemption
universelle conditionnelle,
les Arméniens
que je mentionne
depuis tout à l'heure.
Mais on les appelait
à l'époque
les remontrants.
Et le travail
de ces théologiens
réunis à Dortrèche
a débouché
sur l'un des textes
majeurs de la réforme,
les canons de Dortrèche.
Et ces canons
rejettent fermement
toute idée
d'universalisme,
même hypothétique,
et réaffirment
deux points très importants.
L'élection inconditionnelle,
certains sont prédestinés
au salut,
d'autres à la réprobation,
et l'expiation limitée
ou définie,
c'est-à-dire
le Christ est mort
uniquement
pour ses élus.
On peut lire ça
dans l'article 8
du premier point de doctrine
sur la prédestination.
Il y a donc
des élus et des réprouvés.
Dieu a élu certains
à la vie éternelle
et il a laissé les autres
dans leur chute
et leur condamnation
pour sa justice.
Eh bien,
malgré ces affirmations
très fortes et claires
sur le décret
d'élection de Dieu,
voyez le langage
que l'on retrouve
dans le deuxième point
de doctrine
sur la mort du Christ
et la rédemption.
Je vais lire
quatre articles.
Cette mort du Fils de Dieu
est l'unique
et très parfait sacrifice
et la satisfaction
de la justice de Dieu
pour les péchés,
d'une valeur
et d'un prix infini
qui suffit abondamment
pour expier les péchés
du monde entier.
Article 4.
Cette mort
est d'une si grande valeur
et dignité
parce que la personne
qui l'a soufferte
n'est pas seulement un homme
vrai et parfaitement saint
mais est aussi
le Fils unique de Dieu.
d'une même essence
éternelle et infinie
avec le Père
et le Saint-Esprit
tel que devait être
notre Sauveur.
C'est aussi parce que
sa mort a été conjointe
avec le sentiment
de la colère
et de la malédiction
de Dieu
que nous avions mérité
par nos péchés.
Article 5.
Au reste,
la promesse
de l'Évangile est
afin que quiconque
croit en Jésus-Christ
crucifié
ne périsse point
mais la vie éternelle.
et cette promesse
doit être
indifféremment
annoncée
et proposée
à toutes les nations
et à toutes les personnes
auxquelles Dieu
selon son bon plaisir
envoie l'Évangile
et cela
avec le commandement
de se repentir
et de croire.
Article 6.
Quant à ce que
beaucoup de ceux
qui sont appelés
par l'Évangile
ne se repentent point
ni ne croient en Jésus-Christ
mais périssent
dans l'infidélité,
cela n'arrive point
par l'imperfection
ou l'insuffisance
du sacrifice de Jésus-Christ
offert sur la croix
mais par leur propre faute.
Fin de citation.
J'espère que vous appréciez
l'équilibre
des formulations
de ce texte
entre la suffisance
et l'efficacité
du sang de Christ
pour le salut des hommes.
Voici donc
qui éclaircit pour vous
je l'espère
le langage biblique
et aussi des confessions
de foi historiques
sur la portée universelle
du sacrifice du Christ.
Donc j'ai donc
jusqu'ici répondu
à la première question
en expliquant
ce qui m'avait motivé
à partager cette citation.
Puis j'ai rappelé
que son auteur
n'était pas universaliste
mais plutôt arménien
pour enfin terminer
sur le langage de la Bible
des commentaires
et des documents historiques
sur la façon
de présenter
la portée universelle
du sacrifice
de notre Seigneur Jésus.
Ça c'était pour répondre
au premier aspect
du prélude de la question.
Mais il y a un deuxième aspect
qui est aussi important
l'identité de l'auteur
et je serai plus court
sur cette partie
de la question.
Le prélude aux deux questions
laisse entendre
si je résume
que puisque
M. Joseph Gaume
est un prêtre catholique romain
et ultramontaniste
nous ne devrions pas
le citer.
Nous faisons face ici
à un dilemme sérieux.
Est-ce que c'est la vérité
qui prime
ou celui
qui la proclame ?
Resterais-je sourd
et aveugle
à l'exposition
d'une glorieuse vérité
biblique
parce qu'elle vient
d'une personne
avec qui j'ai
par ailleurs
de profond désaccord ?
Personnellement,
frères et sœurs,
je suis trop attaché
à la vérité,
trop touché
lorsque je la contemple
pour la censurer
sous prétexte
qu'elle n'est pas exprimée
par la bonne personne.
C'est le danger
de la cancel culture.
Où allons-nous
placer le curseur ?
Qu'allons-nous faire
des 1500 années
d'histoire de l'Église
avant la réforme ?
Qu'allez-vous faire
lorsque vous lirez
des pères de l'Église
qui affirment
la régénération baptismale ?
Qu'allez-vous faire
lorsque Luther
affirmait la consubstantation
dans la Sainte Seine ?
De Calvin
qui affirmait
le pédobaptème ?
Ou même d'Arminius,
Jacobus Arminius
qui affirmait
l'universalisme conditionnel
comme nous venons
de le voir.
Et ces trois derniers
que j'ai cités
étaient dans le camp
des réformés.
N'allons-nous plus
jamais en parler
ou les citer
lorsqu'ils disent vrai ?
Et si vous saviez
le nombre de débats
qu'il y a eu
au sein de ce seul
camp réformé
sur bien des doctrines,
cela pourrait aussi
vous troubler
au point de vous dire
je ne peux plus citer
un tel ou un tel
même lorsqu'il dit vrai
sur certains sujets.
Dans la Bible,
l'apôtre Paul
parvient à se réjouir
du fait que l'Évangile
est prêché malgré
les mauvaises motivations
de ceux qui le proclament.
Pourquoi ?
Car il est plus attaché
à la vérité
qu'aux bouches
qui la prononcent.
Philippiens 1
verset 17 à 18
tandis que cela annonce
Christ par ambition
avec des intentions
qui ne sont pas pures
pensant ajouter
de l'affliction
à mes chaînes
qu'importe
de toute manière
que ce soit
avec des arrières-pensées
où sincèrement
Christ est annoncé.
Je m'en réjouis
et je m'en réjouirai encore.
Et pour finir
deux exemples
plus proches de nous
notre pasteur David
cite à l'occasion
C.S. Lewis
c'est vrai
ce n'est pas celui
qu'il cite le plus souvent.
Il le cite malgré
les désaccords profonds
qu'il a avec lui
sur des doctrines importantes.
Les désaccords
qui l'ont même amené
à abandonner l'étude
de son livre
qu'il faisait
avec le groupe d'hommes
il y a plusieurs années
son livre
Les fondements du christianisme.
Après plusieurs chapitres
il a décidé d'arrêter ce livre
parce qu'il avait
des désaccords trop profonds
sur des doctrines importantes
et pourtant
il continue à l'occasion
lorsque c'est pertinent
de le citer.
Un frère
il y a aussi
quelques années
me posait la question
sur Jordan
Peterson
certains d'entre vous
doivent le connaître
c'est un psychologue
et philosophe canadien
qui est devenu assez célèbre
ces dernières années
et il trouvait que
il disait des choses
pertinentes
intéressantes
vraies
édifiantes même
parfois
et je lui disais que
j'étais d'accord
avec lui
mais par contre
je pense que
c'est très dangereux
de s'abreuver
beaucoup
de personnes
telles que lui
sans qu'on ait d'abord
un solide fondement
confessionnel
au préalable
parce qu'on peut
sinon vite
être mené
comme le dit la parole
à tout vent de doctrine
quand on est
solidement fondé
dans notre théologie
dans notre doctrine
on peut
venir
profiter
on peut mieux faire
le tri
filtrer ce qui est dit
bénéficier de certaines
interventions
mais voilà
le terme important
c'est faire le tri
mais si on n'a pas
de base
pour faire le tri
ça devient très dur
de le faire
et donc on peut vite
être perdu
voilà donc
c'est un équilibre
à avoir
mais
ça pourrait arriver
qu'on partage
des citations
d'un Jordan Peterson
qui est éclairant
sur bien des points
donc face à ce dilemme
nous avons deux solutions
pour résumer
on peut ne citer
que les auteurs
avec lesquels
nous estimons
être suffisamment
en accord
donc les critères
de validation
ce seront
les vôtres
et ce ne seront pas
forcément ceux
du frère
assis à côté de vous
dans l'église
ni ceux de l'église
dont vous êtes membre
alors comment réagirez-vous
lorsque un auteur
de votre liste interdite
sera cité par le pasteur
ou par un frère
ou par une sœur
dans l'assemblée
ou nous pouvons
ne pas nous restreindre
selon les auteurs
mais selon la vérité
cela dit
avec deux précautions
importantes
la proportion
et l'explication
ou la mise en garde
et c'est sur ce dernier point
que
j'aurais dû faire
personnellement
attention
après réflexion
au moment de mon partage
je pense que nous avons
suffisamment
de très bons contenus
qui viennent d'auteurs
avec lesquels
nous sommes très majoritairement
en accord
pour ne pas avoir
à partager souvent
des citations d'auteurs
avec lesquels
nous sommes majoritairement
en désaccord
j'aurais pu trouver
un parallèle similaire
et tout aussi édifiant
entre Adam et Chris
chez Augustin
chez Calvin
chez Bullinger
Lloyd-Jones
Sproul ou autres
donc c'est la première précaution
nous devons avoir
de très bonnes raisons
de partager
les citations
d'un auteur problématique
on va dire
et nous assurer
que cela soit rare
par rapport
à nos autres partages
plus évidents
pour ne pas troubler
inutilement
les membres
de l'église
ensuite
même lorsque nous décidons
de le faire
je pense qu'il faut
accompagner
d'explication
si le texte
n'est pas évident
de lui-même
et c'était le cas ici
et d'avertissement
sur l'auteur
s'il peut être
une pierre d'achoppement
comme c'était le cas
ici également
donc dans le cas présent
je pense que j'aurais dû
accompagner cette citation
d'une explication
sur le pourquoi
je fais ce partage
et d'une mise en garde
sur le langage
qui peut être mal compris
ainsi que sur l'auteur
qui est effectivement
un fervent
catholique romain
et cela aurait pu éviter
le trouble de ce frère
ou de cette sœur
qui a envoyé la question
et d'autres
qui ont pu l'être aussi
mais même si je l'ignore
donc j'en profite
pour m'excuser
si ce partage
a plus troublé
que édifié
ceux qui l'ont lu
et donc pour finir
en répondant
à la seconde question
beaucoup plus rapidement
et surtout
est-ce que la chose
a été adressée
au sein du conseil
des anciens
alors non
soit parce qu'ils n'ont
pas vu mon partage
soit parce que
même s'ils l'ont lu
et trouvé problématique
ce n'était pas suffisamment grave
pour que ce soit
un sujet abordé entre nous
soit parce qu'ils voulaient
le faire
mais ils ont oublié
soit parce qu'ils comptent
le faire
mais que ça n'a pas encore
été fait
soit parce qu'ils n'ont pas
soulevé de problème particulier
voilà
j'ai conscience
que c'était une réponse longue
mais je crois
que c'était important
de prendre le temps
d'y répondre
pour éclaircir
voilà
tous les sujets
qui étaient liés
à cette question
voilà
du coup
c'était la plus
la plus compliquée
on va dire celle-là
ça va être un peu plus
un peu plus simple
je pense
donc une question
qui porte sur le lien
c'est plutôt une question
d'exégèse
le lien entre
Ézéchiel et Acte
donc je cite la question
est-ce que selon vous
Paul fait un lien
avec Ézéchiel 33
verset 4 à 8
donc vous pouvez ouvrir
ces deux passages
si vous le souhaitez
Ézéchiel 33
4 à 8
on lira 1 à 9
pour un peu plus de contexte
et Acte 20
verset 26 à 27
lorsque Paul dit
je suis pur du sang
de vous tous
qu'est-ce qu'il veut dire
sommes-nous concernés
lorsque par exemple
nous manquons
des opportunités
de témoignage
par l'évangélisation
fin de la question
donc je vous invite
tout d'abord
à lire Ézéchiel 33
verset 1 à 9
donc Dieu s'adresse
ici au prophète Ézéchiel
fils de l'homme
parle aux enfants
de ton peuple
et dis-leur
lorsque je fais venir
l'épée sur un pays
et que le peuple du pays
prend dans son sein
un homme
et l'établit
comme sentinelle
si cet homme
voit venir l'épée
sur le pays
sonne de la trompette
et avertit le peuple
et si celui-ci
si celui qui entend
le son de la trompette
ne se laisse pas avertir
et que l'épée
vienne le surprendre
son sang sera
sur sa tête
il a entendu
le son de la trompette
et il ne s'est pas
laisser avertir
son sang sera sur lui
s'il se laisse avertir
il sauvera son âme
si la sentinelle
voit venir l'épée
et ne sonne pas
de la trompette
si le peuple
n'est pas averti
et que l'épée
vienne enlever
à quelqu'un la vie
celui-ci périra
à cause de son iniquité
mais je redemanderai
son sang
à la sentinelle
et toi
fils de l'homme
je t'ai établi
comme sentinelle
sur la maison d'Israël
tu dois écouter
la parole
qui sort de ma bouche
et les avertir
de ma part
quand je dis au méchant
méchant tu mourras
si tu ne parles pas
pour détourner
le méchant
de sa voix
ce méchant
mourra dans son iniquité
et je te redemanderai
son sang
mais si tu avertis
le méchant
pour le détourner
de sa voix
et qu'il ne s'en détourne pas
il mourra
dans son iniquité
et toi
tu sauveras
ton âme
Amen
donc voyons d'abord
de quoi il est question
dans ce passage
l'éternel
s'adresse au prophète
Ézéchiel
sous l'appellation
fils de l'homme
qui nous rappelle
évidemment
Christ
le prophète suprême
au milieu de son peuple
l'éternel
a établi
Ézéchiel
comme sentinelle
sur la maison d'Israël
et sa mission
c'est d'appeler
à la repentance
les enfants de son peuple
qui s'obstinent
dans leurs péchés
notamment
et comme la sentinelle
veille à la sécurité
du peuple
en les avertissant
du danger
qu'il les guette
Ézéchiel doit avertir
le peuple
du danger
qui les guette
en tout cas
ceux qui vivent
dans le péché
ce danger
étant les conséquences
de leur péché
dans cette vie
donc guerre
destruction
déportation
et ultimement
le châtiment éternel
de l'enfer
pour leur âme
et tout comme
la sentinelle
d'une ville
serait criminelle
et coupable
de trahison même
si elle laissait
s'approcher
une armée ennemie
de la ville
sans donner l'alerte
et bien le prophète
qui est appelé par Dieu
du saint
de son peuple
qui n'avertirait pas
le peuple
du danger spirituel
qui s'approche de lui
à cause de son péché
serait criminel
et complice
de Satan
si le prophète
ne parle pas
pour détourner
le méchant
de sa voix
ce méchant mourra
dans son iniquité
et Dieu
lui redemandera
son sang
il en sera responsable
il est donc intéressant
de noter
que la mission
d'Ézéchiel
a pour but
d'avertir
le peuple
de Dieu
des graves conséquences
de son péché
son péché
non repenti
c'est un appel
à la repentance
interne
au peuple
de Dieu
puisque la question
porte sur
l'évangélisation
d'accord
on y reviendra après
lisons maintenant
le passage en actes
actes 20
verset 20 à 27
Paul s'adresse
à une église
qu'il a implantée
et notamment
aux anciens
de cette église
vous savez
que je n'ai rien
caché
de ce qui vous était
utile
et que je n'ai pas
craint de vous prêcher
et de vous enseigner
publiquement
et dans les maisons
annonçant aux juifs
et aux grecs
la repentance
envers Dieu
et la foi
en notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
et maintenant
voici
lié par l'esprit
je vais à Jérusalem
ne sachant pas
ce qui m'y arrivera
seulement de ville
en ville
l'esprit saint
m'avertit
que des liens
et des tribulations
m'attendent
mais je ne fais
pour moi-même
aucun cas de ma vie
comme si elle m'était
précieuse
pourvu que j'accomplisse
ma course avec joie
et le ministère
que j'ai reçu
du Seigneur Jésus
d'annoncer
la bonne nouvelle
de la grâce de Dieu
et maintenant
voici
je sais que vous
ne verrez plus mon visage
vous tous
au milieu desquels
j'ai passé
en prêchant
le royaume de Dieu
c'est pourquoi
je vous déclare
aujourd'hui
que je suis pur
du sang de vous tous
car
je vous ai annoncé
tout le conseil
de Dieu
sans en rien
cacher
Amen
donc Paul aussi
a été appelé
par le Christ
pour prêcher
l'évangile
aux gentils
et aux juifs
même ici
et édifier son église
par sa parole
de vérité
et Paul a fidèlement
répondu à cet appel
nous le voyons
dans ce passage
il était constamment
soumis à la direction
de l'Esprit Saint
il persévérait
malgré la persécution
dans la prédication
et l'enseignement public
envers les juifs
envers les grecs
Paul devait
comme Ézéchiel
écouter la parole
qui sort de la bouche
de l'éternel
et avertir le peuple
de la part de Dieu
et l'apôtre Paul
fut une sentinelle fidèle
qui a veillé
sur l'église
faisant peu de cas
de sa propre vie
par amour pour Christ
et pour son église
c'est pourquoi il peut affirmer
je suis pur
du sang de vous tous
car je vous ai annoncé
tout le conseil de Dieu
sans n'en rien cacher
ce rôle de sentinelle
c'est d'ailleurs
celui de chaque pasteur
chaque pasteur
qui est aussi
pris du sein de l'église
et établi
comme ancien
ou sentinelle
on pourrait dire
sur l'assemblée
regardez ce que Paul dit
dans le verset qui suit
le verset 28
il s'adresse là
aux anciens
prenez donc garde
à vous-même
et à tout le troupeau
sur lequel le Saint-Esprit
vous a établi évêques
pour paître
l'église du Seigneur
qui s'est acquise
par son propre sang
mais ce rôle
ce n'est pas seulement
celui du prophète
dans l'Ancien Testament
ou de l'Ancien
dans l'église
c'est celui
de chaque chrétien
qui est appelé par Christ
à veiller sur son frère
disons quelques versets
par rapport à cela
Jacques
qui a même un vocabulaire
un peu similaire
à celui du prophète
Ézéchiel
mais frère
si quelqu'un parmi vous
s'est égaré
loin de la vérité
et qu'un autre
l'y ramène
qu'il sache
que celui qui ramène
un pécheur
de la voie
où il s'est égaré
sauvera une âme
de la mort
et couvrira
une multitude
de péchés
le Seigneur Jésus
a dit en Matthieu 18
verset 15
si ton frère a péché
va et reprends-le
entre toi
et lui seul
s'il t'écoute
tu as gagné ton frère
et l'apôtre Paul
1 Thessaloniciens 5
verset 11 à 14
encouragez-vous donc
les uns les autres
et édifiez-vous
réciproquement
nous vous en prions frère
avertissez
ceux qui vivent
dans le désordre
consoler ceux
qui sont abattus
supporter les faibles
user de patience
envers tous
donc je pense donc
que Paul veut
en effet dire
qu'il a accompli
au milieu de ses chrétiens
tout ce que le Seigneur
l'appelait à dire
et à faire
il a parfaitement
et fidèlement
rempli sa mission
si eux se détournent
par la suite
des voies du Seigneur
il n'en sera pas tenu
pour responsable
par Dieu
il est libre
de leur sang
Dieu ne lui
redemandera pas
leur sang
car il aura été
une sentinelle fidèle
exhortant le peuple
de Dieu
à la repentance
et à la fidélité
envers le Sauveur
et Seigneur Jésus-Christ
sommes-nous concernés
lorsque par exemple
nous manquons des opportunités
de témoignage
par l'évangélisation
c'est la deuxième partie
de la question
alors je dirais d'abord
que ces versets
sont plutôt un avertissement
pour les chrétiens
qui ne veillent pas
les uns sur les autres
au sein de l'église
comme on a vu
que ce soit
dans la citation
d'Ézéchiel
ou Paul
c'est une discussion
à l'intérieur de l'église
d'abord
mais par extension
c'est un avertissement
pour tout chrétien
qui se tait
lorsqu'il sait
qu'il devrait parler
que ce soit envers son frère
qu'il doit reprendre
encourager
etc.
ou un collègue
qui doit lui aussi
exhorter à la repentance
même s'il n'est pas encore
il n'a pas encore vécu
de première repentance
on va dire
dans tous les moments
pardon
tous les moments
où nous savons
que Dieu nous appelle
à parler
si nous ne le faisons pas
et bien
nous sommes concernés
aussi par extension
par cet avertissement
et donc je pense
que nous devrions
ressentir effectivement
de la tristesse
lorsque nous manquons
une opportunité
d'évangélisation
surtout si cela
est le fruit
de la peur des hommes
ou de péchés
comme la paresse
ou des mauvaises priorités
dans notre vie
on a plus envie
de nous rendre
à un autre rendez-vous
ou à telle activité
plutôt que
de nous arrêter
pour évangéliser
une personne
maintenant
il ne faut pas
passer plus de temps
à s'accabler
sur les occasions
qu'on a manqué
que sur les prochaines
opportunités
qui peuvent arriver
très vite
dans la providence
de Dieu
surtout si nous prions
pour en avoir
mais nous devons
rester très vigilants
pour ne pas manquer
ces opportunités
c'est sûr
que ce soit
dans l'église
ou à l'extérieur
que Dieu nous donne
d'appeler
ceux qui en ont besoin
à la repentance
et à se saisir
de la grâce de Dieu
en Jésus Christ
voilà donc c'est
d'abord
ça ne concerne pas
directement l'évangélisation
mais par extension
il y a des applications
pour l'évangélisation
on va prendre au moins
une troisième question
quand même
qui concerne
la beauté des églises
j'ai essayé aussi
de prendre des sujets
assez variés
donc la question
est la suivante
est-ce qu'un chrétien
devrait attribuer
de la beauté
aux églises
dans lesquelles sont faites
des représentations
idolâtres du Christ
statues
peintures
dessins
en dépit
de la qualité
architecturale
Dieu a formellement
interdit sa représentation
par des images
quelconques
peut-on donc conclure
que ces lieux
sont des temples païens
fin de la question
donc par rapport
au bâtiment lui-même
on peut reprendre
quelques éléments
de réponse
que j'évoquais
dans la première question
la vérité est objective
peu importe
qui la prononce
ça ne veut pas dire
que celui qui la prononce
n'a aucune importance
mais voilà
la vérité reste la vérité
et je pense que c'est
la même chose
pour la beauté
la beauté est objective
et même si elle est
toujours imparfaite
ici-bas
on peut la reconnaître
et l'apprécier
malgré tous ses défauts
et c'est indéniable
qu'un temple protestant
qu'une cathédrale gothique
qu'une église byzantine
sont beaux
en tout cas
pour ceux qui trouvent ça moche
souvent les explications
sont intéressantes
mais Nadia et moi
on s'est mariés
dans un temple protestant
en Alsace
et à chaque fois
que ça nous arrive
de montrer les photos
de la cérémonie
les personnes commentent
la beauté du bâtiment
donc c'est assez universel
de reconnaître
la beauté de manière générale
et notamment
dans ces bâtiments-là
donc oui
c'est possible
de reconnaître
la beauté
d'un tel bâtiment
en faisant abstraction
de ses défauts
même les graves défauts
comme les statues
qui peuvent s'y trouver
les statues de Marie
les statues de Saint
ou peinture
des saints
ou autre
je ne dis pas du tout
qu'on pourrait célébrer
nos cultes
dans un bâtiment
comme ça
tel quel
avec tous ces éléments
loin de là
je ne dis pas
que ces éléments
ne sont pas un problème
c'est un grave problème
ou que Dieu
ne s'en soucie pas
je dis simplement
qu'on peut trouver
une église belle
malgré ces éléments
si on ne parle que
de l'architecture
d'accord
ensuite
puisqu'il y a plusieurs
questions dans la question
sur les représentations
du Christ
c'est tout un
voilà je ne vais pas
du tout m'étendre
parce que c'est un sujet
très vaste
mais c'est encore
un autre sujet
sachez simplement
qu'il y a eu
et qu'il y a encore
des positions diverses
sur ce sujet précis
de la représentation
du Christ
même parmi
les réformateurs
les plus proches
de nos convictions
d'accord
et c'est pareil
pour les représentations
de Dieu
donc est-ce qu'on parle
par exemple
de représentation
anthropomorphique
où on voit Dieu
sous les traits
d'un vieillard
est-ce qu'on parle
de représentation
métaphorique
ou allégorique
avec des rayons
de soleil
un triangle
ou des choses
comme ça
donc personnellement
j'adopterai
au minimum
le principe
de précaution
surtout pour
les lieux de culte
pas de représentation
de Dieu
de Christ
dans une église
et je placerai
donc toutes ces
représentations
évidemment
dans les éléments
problématiques
d'une église
qui ne devrait pas
s'y trouver
maintenant
est-ce que nous
devrions considérer
de telles églises
comme des temples
païens
c'est intéressant
comme question
je trouve ça
assez dur
de faire une généralité
c'est plus du cas par cas
surtout basé
sur les convictions
de l'église
qui utilise ce bâtiment
imaginons une église
pas un bâtiment
mais une assemblée
qui adore le vrai
Dieu trinitaire
qui proclame
l'évangile
qui confesse
le symbole des apôtres
le symbole de Nicée
qui est fidèle
aux doctrines
historiques de l'église
qui se réunit
dans un bâtiment
où le Christ
est représenté
que ce soit en peinture
ou autre
je ne pense pas
que j'irai jusqu'à dire
qu'il s'agit
d'un temple païen
car l'église
qui s'y réunit
est une église
authentique
je dirais
qu'il s'agit
d'une erreur
à faire rectifier
au plus tôt
par un bon peintre
en bâtiment
ça ne devrait pas
être là
il faut vite l'enlever
d'accord
je voudrais terminer
avec une anecdote
que mon cher frère
Christian
m'a envoyé
il y a peu
un édit
du 28 janvier
accorda
une suspension
des persécutions
pour les réformer
donc des réfugiés
revinrent dans leur pays
en Allemagne
Genève
Angleterre
et le nombre
des pasteurs
et des congrégations
allaient en s'augmentant
les protestants
abusant parfois
de cette nouvelle
liberté fragile
se livrèrent
à la destruction
des images
et des reliques
qui ornaient
les édifices
de l'église
catholique romaine
Calvin écrivait
de Genève
d'énergie
protestation
contre ces scandales
iconoclastes
c'est à dire
contre les statues
et autres
et affirmer
que Dieu
n'autorise pas
les chrétiens
à détruire
les idoles
voilà
c'est juste
encore une fois
pour apporter
un peu de nuance
et voilà
mais clairement
si vous demandez
mon avis
au minimum
sans dire
voilà je pense
que c'est un péché
qui désobéit
au second commandement
etc
je pense que
le minimum
qu'on devrait adopter
c'est le principe
de précaution
et ne pas avoir
de telles représentations
surtout pas
dans les lieux de culte
on pourrait même
étendre
à d'autres contextes
mais dans les églises
évidemment
voilà
je sais que c'est un sujet
qui revient souvent
il y a aussi
en fait
au-delà de cette question
quelque chose
que j'entendais
très souvent
par le passé
enfin que j'ai
très souvent entendu
c'est
oui mais
tout cet argent
qu'on a mis
ou qu'on met
dans les bâtiments
on pense surtout
quand on voit
le
à Rome
comme ça
avec beaucoup
énormément de richesses
visibles
en fait
dans le bâtiment
lui-même
avec les dorures
les sculptures
tout ça
tout cet argent
on aurait pu l'investir
dans des choses
vraiment plus importantes
comme la mission
à travers le monde
le soin des plus démunis
etc.
dans la société
et si on présente
comme ça
les choses
c'est sûr
c'est vrai
que la priorité
c'est pas d'avoir
un bâtiment
aussi fourni
de richesses
et de détails
c'est pas
voilà
après
il ne faut pas
non plus
oublier le contexte
si on parle
des cathédrales
par exemple
on est dans
des contextes
où c'est une nation
entière
qui est chrétienne
et toute nation
qui a une religion
officielle
ça se manifeste
concrètement
par des bâtiments
par des choses
comme ça
et il y avait aussi
de l'argent investi
dans d'autres domaines
donc c'est un peu
c'est proportionnel
si vous voulez
oui les bâtiments
sont impressionnants
mais il y avait aussi
des choses impressionnantes
qui étaient faites ailleurs
alors c'est moins vrai
surtout à la fin
au moment où il y a eu
la réforme
parce que c'est précisément
ça qui posait problème
aux réformateurs
mais je pense par exemple
à des contextes
comme les Etats-Unis
aujourd'hui
où vous pouvez voir
des bâtiments
incroyables
très très grands
magnifiques
alors ils ne sont pas
ostentatoires
en termes de dorures
etc.
mais ils sont très grands
probablement ils ont coûté
cher à construire
etc.
mais ce sont aussi
les églises et les ministères
qui investissent le plus
dans le soutien
de familles missionnaires
à travers le monde
dans les oeuvres sociales
là où ils sont
enfin voilà
je pense que si on faisait
la proportion
ils doivent investir
plus ailleurs
que dans leur église
mais quand on voit
leur église
on se dit
oulala
incroyable
tout l'argent
qu'ils ont dû mettre
là-dedans
oui mais
ils ont mis
encore plus
ailleurs
donc il faut faire
attention aussi
à comment on juge
les choses
c'est moins vrai
pour les cathédras
il y a eu vraiment
des abus
et le peuple
spirituellement
l'argent n'était
pas du tout
bien investi
parce que même
les
ah le mot m'échappe
ce qu'on de quoi
Luther a beaucoup
protesté
où il fallait mettre
l'argent
pour
oui indulgence
j'avais doléance
en tête
les indulgences
c'était précisément
pour financer
des projets de construction
de cathédrales
ou des choses comme ça
donc c'était vraiment
voilà c'était fait
à l'envers
mais c'est juste
pour apporter
un peu de nuances
surtout dans le contexte
plus contemporain
où on voit
des beaux bâtiments
ils utilisent mal
l'argent
il faut attendre
de voir comment
ils utilisent
ailleurs aussi
de toute façon
je pense qu'on va
finir avec une dernière
question rapide
beaucoup plus pratique
un peu plus
entre guillemets
légère
le conseil pratique
pour notre vie
d'église à nous
aujourd'hui
je voulais quand même
la traiter
parce qu'elle est
importante
et plus pratique
donc voilà
et donc la question
c'est
dans notre contexte
actuel
à l'église Bonne Nouvelle
comment concrètement
s'encourager
à notre progrès
spirituel
entre frères et sœurs
comment pouvons-nous
mettre à profit
tous les bons enseignements
du dimanche
et du vendredi
pour que réellement
en pratique
nous nous encourageons
à apporter du fruit
de l'esprit
donc là
je vais simplement
vous livrer
quelques idées
de choses qu'on peut faire
la semaine
c'est plutôt la semaine
je laisserai Stéphane
compléter
il est très pertinent
souvent sur ces aspects-là
aussi
mais donc voilà
je dirais
commençons simplement
sanctifions véritablement
nos dimanches
passons la journée
ensemble
discutons entre nous
de la prédication
discutons de sujets
spirituels
de nos lectures
de la semaine
soyons intentionnels
c'est un mot
qui va énormément
revenir dans mes
dans mes propositions
dans mes conseils
mais commençons
simplement
avec le jour qu'on a
qui est fait pour ça
le dimanche
on vient pas juste au culte
et puis on s'en va juste après
on essaie de rester ensemble
on s'invite
ou on se laisse inviter
on fait les efforts
même s'il y a la fatigue
des contraintes
et surtout
on
voilà
on se laisse pas aller
au
au gré des discussions
on essaie d'être intentionnel
on ramène sur
la prédication
qui vient d'être
écoutée
sur des passages
bibliques qu'on a lus
on
on prie ensemble
etc.
on vraiment
on essaie de sanctifier
véritablement ce jour-là
en semaine
on invite
intentionnellement
des connaissances
non chrétiennes
ou des membres
d'autres églises
qu'on connaît
des églises en mauvaise santé
et on inclut
dans notre invitation
des frères et des sœurs
de l'église
pour participer ensemble
à l'évangélisation
de ces personnes
ça resserre vraiment
les liens aussi
de faire ce travail
ensemble
en plus d'exercer
l'hospitalité
invitons le plus possible
les frères et sœurs
qui vivent proches
de chez nous
évidemment
c'est le plus simple
commençons par ça
faisons des efforts
pour les inviter
pour accepter les invitations
et pour faire
de ces moments précieux
une priorité
dans notre agenda
plus qu'un club sportif
une sortie au cinéma
ou d'autres choses comme ça
faisons-en une priorité
dans la semaine
soyons proactifs
dans le discipula
la lecture de livres
en petits groupes
ou même
dans un groupe plus large
comme les femmes
les femmes de l'église
ou les hommes de l'église
prenons la liste des membres
et mettons en place
une discipline hebdomadaire
pour envoyer un message
à un ou plusieurs membres
pour prendre des nouvelles
pour prier pour eux
et avec eux
et ne restons pas en contact
qu'avec les membres
avec lesquels nous sommes
le plus à l'aise
mais allons intentionnellement
vers les autres aussi
pour apprendre à les connaître
si nous ne les connaissons pas
nous ne saurons pas
comment prier pour eux
nous ne créerons pas de lien
avec eux
le vendredi
le dimanche
soyons intentionnels
dans nos discussions
j'ai déjà dit
les questions qu'on se pose
allons plus loin
que de demander
comment va la santé
mais par exemple
posons cette question
que je viens de lire
comment pourrais-je concrètement
t'encourager
dans tes progrès spirituels
ou comment est-ce que
tu as mis en pratique
ce que tu as entendu
dans la prédication
la semaine dernière
voici comment je
comment Dieu m'a aidé
personnellement
à le mettre en pratique
dans ma semaine
soyons intentionnels
dans les sujets
qu'on lance
donc voilà
comme vous l'aurez remarqué
je pense que la réponse
à cette question
elle repose en très grande partie
sur l'intentionnalité
que nous mettrons
dans nos échanges
et dans nos relations
au sein de l'Assemblée
si on passe peu de temps
ensemble la semaine
à nous de tout faire
pour que ce temps
soit le plus rentable
spirituellement parlant
posons des questions
sur notre sanctification
sur des sujets doctrinaux
partageons des sujets de prière
prions directement
pour ces sujets
ne disons pas
je prierai pour cela
mais faisons-le sur place
nous devons créer
une culture d'église
où il devient normal
et instinctif
que ce soit ce type d'échange
et d'activité
qui caractérise
nos rassemblements
que ce soit le vendredi soir
le dimanche
ou en semaine
voilà quelques
c'est loin d'être exhaustif
mais quelques directions
qu'on peut prendre
et puis on peut prendre
le dimanche
on peut prendre
et puis on peut prendre
le dimanche
pour le dimanche
et puis on peut prendre
le dimanche
pour le dimanche
et puis on peut prendre
le dimanche
pour le dimanche
et puis on peut prendre
le dimanche
pour le dimanche